c'est l'histoire d'un légume rarement
sous les feux des projecteurs tout comme
son cousin avec qui on le confond
souvent et pourtant n'avait et rutabaga
mérite d'être reconnu et cuisiné pour ne
plus passer pour des légumes mal aimés
[Musique]
navet et rutabaga ont tout de même leurs
amateurs parmi lesquels Yves gagnant ce
minciés et auteur et la créer le jardin
du Grand portage dans Lanaudière il y a
43 ans il a une infection particulière
pour les rutabaga qu'il cultivent dans
son jardin est-ce qu'on peut voir ce
qu'il faut alors on a ici un beau
spécimen de rutabaga qui est pas tout à
fait prêt mais on va le récolter quand
même c'est une belle taille puis son
gros lui son temps c'est pas vrai avec
tous les légumes on va tailler un petit
peu la racine comme ça et on se retrouve
avec un légume comme on les trouve à
l'épicerie j'aimerais qu'on retrace
l'historique et l'origine des navets et
du rutabaga le navet est apparu avant le
rutabaga il est probablement issu d'une
plante indigène qu'on trouvait un peu
partout en Eurasie le rutabaga lui
serait probablement
issu d'un croisement entre le navet et
un chou à feuilles au début autant de la
colonie de la Nouvelle France plutôt du
navet qui était utilisé puis quand
le rutabaga est arrivé au début du 19e
siècle ben il y a remplacé le navet dans
les préparations hivernales
[Musique]
on consomme une seule espèce de rutabaga
à colle violet sa chair et orangée et
sucré quand on avait aussi appelé rabiol
il en existe plusieurs variétés la plus
commune est blanche et mauve souvent
jugé trop amer alors qu'il existe
d'autres variétés de plus en plus
prisées au goût moins prononcé alors ici
on a un navet qui a été probablement
développé en Asie qui s'appelle le high
kuri on a également un navet rouge qui
s'appelle le Scarlet au nom du Viber qui
est très intéressant pour rouge
intérieur blanc avec des veines de rose
c'est très beau notre boule d'or qui est
à charge jaunâtre donc il y a beaucoup
de diversité le rutabaga est
relativement sucré je trouve demain il y
a une chaire orange alors que très
souvent le navet va avoir une chair
blanche
[Musique]
ici n'avait et rutabaga ont souvent été
associés bouillie de nos grands-mères il
existe aujourd'hui des façons plus
originales de cuisiner ses légumes je
trouve qu'il y a tellement de créativité
aujourd'hui en gastronomie québécoise
donc on redonne à une multitude de
légumes racines leur lettres de noblesse
[Musique]
et
c'est exactement le mandat que c'est
donner le chef Vincent Lévesque le page
dans son restaurant de Montréal il met
de l'avant les légumes d'ici sur son
menu du rutabaga mariné et lacto
fermentés et sa création un rutabaga en
croûte de sel comment tu procèdes tout
simple deux ingrédients celles et blanc
d'oeuf donc on va verser les blancs
d'oeufs les montées en neige et par la
suite on va venir plier avec une maryse
le sel à l'intérieur et maintenant
faire une petite assise un peu pour le
rutabaga
[Musique]
donc on vient vraiment
enrobé comme on ferait avec un glaçage à
gâteau
et non ce n'est pas une île flottante
[Rires]
donc après 90 minutes environ au four
enfin on a notre rutabaga en croûte
comment on procède pour le sortir de ce
qu'on habitait
la croûte de sel
on va maintenant procéder à l'éplucher
donc on vient se couper une belle petite
tranche comme ça dans notre état Baga
on vient par la suite déposer la fameuse
sauce
[Musique]
j'ai par la suite rajouter des petites
rabioles et voilà nous allons donc un
rutabaga en croûte de sel sauce crème
sur et l'hiver rabiole et navet mariné
et qui nous a pris sur le dessus prête à
goûter moi on y va on y va
[Musique]
pas su dire que c'est un rutabaga
tellement que les arômes sont beaucoup
plus sucrés vraiment plus intense
que tu viens de redorer l'image du
rutabaga merci Vincent merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup c'était mon plaisir
[Musique]